Shure: OK你别趴冲了再给我冲倒就行
Shure: OK, don't rush, just don't knock it over again.
Shure的女友:你摔了老公
Shure's GF: You fell, honey.
Shure: 是吧
Shure: Right?
Shure: 杨老板呢 杨老板
Shure: Where's Jake? Jake?
Shure: 杨老板在外头好像 来吧
Shure: Jake's outside, I think. Come on.
Jake:对啊
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:想不起来
Jake: Can't remember.
Jake:不想了吧
Jake: Let's not think about it.
Shure: 来快快快
Shure: Come on, come on, come on.
Shure: 下来下来下来
Shure: Down, down, down.
Tasha:怎么又下来了都
Tasha: Why is everyone coming down again?
女嘉宾:下来开香槟
Female Guest: Coming down to open champagne.
Tasha:下来
Tasha: Coming down.
Tasha:开完香槟然后就结束了吗
Tasha: After opening the champagne, is it over?
Shure: 呃
Shure: Uh...
Tasha:还是继续是吧
Tasha: Or does it continue?
Shure的女友:应该没有吧
Shure's GF: There shouldn't be any, right?
Shure: 随便随便都可以
Shure: It's all good, anything's fine.
Tasha:那去楼上开香槟那为啥不
Tasha: Then why don't we go upstairs to open the champagne?
Jake:对我们会帮你们先删
Jake: Yeah, we'll help you delete it first.
Shure: 因为这个东西看完咱们要脱呀
Shure: Because after we watch this, we gotta take it off.
Shure: 它会崩的一课地都是 你知道吧
Shure: It'll pop everywhere, you know that, right?
Shure的女友:你你你把那个铁丝拧开的时候
Shure's GF: When you twist the wire,
Shure的女友:你手在这里压一下
Shure's GF: press your hand here.
Shure的女友:他不会太绷
Shure's GF: It won't pop too much.
Shure的女友:你把他所有气放完
Shure's GF: Let all the gas out.
Shure的女友:我我我我我怕手折
Shure's GF: I'm, I'm, I'm afraid my hand will break.
Shure: 来吧来吧
Shure: Come on, come on.
Shure: 来杨老板
Shure: Come on, Jake.
Alice:有但但没有录
Alice: There is, but it's not recorded.
Jake:开开开开
Jake: Open, open, open, open.
Shure: ego life圆满收官
Shure: Ego life comes to a perfect end.
Shure: 好吧
Shure: Alright.
Shure: 快快快快下来下来下来下来来
Shure: Quick, quick, quick, come down, come down, come down.
Nicous: 就他就他一个不是哥们
Nicous: He's the only one who's not a buddy.
Katrina: 完了
Katrina: It's over.
Nicous: 你是不是邀请他了
Nicous: Did you invite him?
男嘉宾:你是不是跟他一个人过来的
Male Guest: Did you come with him?
Katrina: 因为我就北京就他一个熟一点的
Katrina: Because he's the only one I know well in Beijing.
男嘉宾:那你今天下午不是跟他坐在这
Male Guest: Weren't you sitting with him this afternoon?
男嘉宾:跟他一直坐
Male Guest: Sitting with him all the time.
Katrina: 因为我坐在他们俩
Katrina: Because I was sitting between the two of them.
男嘉宾:这个男人同学说
Male Guest: This guy said,
男嘉宾:哎呀刘宇轩怎么一直挑着我啊
Male Guest: Hey, why is Liu Yuxuan always picking on me?
男嘉宾:哇刘宇轩挑着我表白啊
Male Guest: Wow, Liu Yuxuan is picking on me to confess.
男嘉宾:他邀请我竟然没有跟我表白
Male Guest: He invited me but didn't confess to me.
Shure: 真的
Shure: Really?
Shure: 瞅瞅说什么说什么
Shure: Look, look, what are they saying?
Shure: 是不是偷偷说我坏话了
Shure: Are they secretly badmouthing me?
Jake:拿出来看看
Jake: Take it out and see.
Shure的女友:没有我说接孩子放学啊
Shure's GF: No, I said picking up the kids from school.
Shure的女友:接孩子刚才那些啊
Shure's GF: Picking up the kids earlier.
Shure: 走吧走吧
Shure: Let's go, let's go.
Tasha:什么
Tasha: What?
Shure: 院院里
Shure: In the courtyard.
Shure: 把香槟开了就完事了
Shure: Just open the champagne and it's done.
Nicous: 竟然看不出来那男的喜欢她了
Nicous: How could you not see that guy likes her?
男嘉宾:你觉得
Male Guest: Do you think...
男嘉宾:你觉得今天下午可以邀请来那个
Male Guest: Do you think we could invite...
男嘉宾:用刀开
Male Guest: Use a knife to open it.
Shure: 不用不用不用
Shure: No, no, no.
Tasha:那不然我来干嘛
Tasha: Otherwise, why am I here?
Shure: 来 杨老板 没你不行
Shure: Come on, Jake, we need you.
Shure: 啊哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
男嘉宾:看到没有牛逼看到没有
Male Guest: Did you see that? Awesome, right?
Alice:然后第二天把冰箱里的 不是
Alice: And then the next day, take out the stuff from the fridge. No, wait...
男嘉宾:一句话
Male Guest: One sentence.
Katrina: 不可以邀请朋友过来就朋友
Katrina: You can't invite friends over, just friends.
Lucia:对
Lucia: Right.
Nicous: 我他妈喊了一万个人
Nicous: I called a thousand people.
Nicous: 你看有人吗
Nicous: Do you see anyone?
Nicous: 哈哈哈但但你只要求
Nicous: Hahaha, but you only asked for...
Nicous: 通州啊通州啊
Nicous: Tongzhou, Tongzhou!
Nicous: 来回
Nicous: Back and forth.
男嘉宾:通州很远
Male Guest: Tongzhou is far.
男嘉宾:他在清华跟我们来的距离是一样的
Male Guest: He's at Tsinghua, it's the same distance for us.
Nicous: 太远了 我草
Nicous: Too far, damn it.
男嘉宾:哈哈哈巨远
Male Guest: Hahaha, very far.
Katrina: 有点想死
Katrina: I kind of want to die.
Nicous: 采访一下
Nicous: Let's interview.
Nicous: 你觉得那个男生喜欢他吗
Nicous: Do you think that guy likes her?
Jack: 婧康有女朋友他应该能感受出来
Jack: Jingkang has a girlfriend, he should know.
女嘉宾:谁有女朋友啊
Female Guest: Who has a girlfriend?
女嘉宾:你有女朋友啊
Female Guest: You have a girlfriend?
Jake:以前有过
Jake: I used to.
Jake:以前有现在没有
Jake: I used to, not anymore.
Nicous: 不好意思哎我不是故意的
Nicous: Sorry, I didn't mean to.
Shure: 哈哈哈 来来来
Shure: Hahaha, come on, come on.
Nicous: 我操
Nicous: Damn it.
Shure: 来来来
Shure: Come on, come on.
Nicous: 完了我靠完了
Nicous: It's over, damn it, it's over.
Shure: 康康神咱们先把香槟开了
Shure: Kang, let's open the champagne first.
Jake:好好好
Jake: Okay, okay, okay.
Nicous: 卧槽卧槽
Nicous: Whoa, whoa.
Nicous: 完了卧槽
Nicous: It's over, damn it.
Tasha:提起了人家的伤心史
Tasha: Brought up someone's sad history.
Jack: 节约人品你同等开一个是一个
Jack: Save your luck, open one at a time.
Nicous: 卧槽卧槽
Nicous: Whoa, whoa.
Alice:哦那可能是
Alice: Oh, that might be...
Jake:我我我觉
Jake: I, I, I think...
Jake:得也有 哈哈哈
Jake: It might be too, hahaha.
Shure: 来来来
Shure: Come on, come on.
Shure: 一起一起来
Shure: Let's all do it together.
Alice:有东西不知道是啥
Alice: There's something, not sure what it is.
Shure: come om
Shure: Come on.
Shure: 小心崩到你的电脑哦
Shure: Be careful not to hit your computer.
Jake: 好嘞 我们先开香槟
Jake: Alright, let's open the champagne first.
Shure的女友:某种意义上
Shure's GF: In a way...
Shure的女友:其实我不太在意你们两个人什么关系
Shure's GF: Actually, I don't really care about your relationship.
Shure的女友:啊但是他的视线就是占比
Shure's GF: But his gaze is pretty telling.
Shure的女友:大概是
Shure's GF: Maybe...
Shure的女友:往往往然后往大家那里视线扫两眼
Shure's GF: He often glances at everyone, but most of the time it's on you.
Shure的女友:然后剩下的时间都在你这
Shure's GF: The rest of the time, his eyes are on you.
Jack: 这可是非常骗不了人的
Jack: That's something you can't fake.
Katrina: 啊真的吗
Katrina: Really?
Shure: 就应该把这个眼球追踪都给他追踪到
Shure: We should use eye tracking on him.
Tasha:要脱单了吗
Tasha: Is he going to be single?
Shure: 你知道吧
Shure: You know...
Katrina: 我只觉得有点奇怪的是
Katrina: What I find strange is...
Katrina: 他为啥老让他给我俩拍合照
Katrina: Why does he always want to take pictures of us?
Katrina: 他给我俩拍合照
Katrina: He takes pictures of the two of us.
Katrina: 明明我们一直在拍情侣
Katrina: Even though we are always taking couple photos.
Katrina: 他非要就一直跟我俩拍照
Katrina: He insists on taking pictures with us.
Nicous: 好孺子不可教也
Nicous: A good student can't be taught.
Shure: 不不不咱咱先把香槟开了回
Shure: No, no, let's open the champagne first.
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed.
Nicous: 其实我觉得你邀请他过来就是那意思
Nicous: Actually, I think you inviting him over means...
Nicous: 因为你俩
Nicous: Because you two...
Jack: 就你邀请的人家
Jack: You invited him.
Jack: 难道不是
Jack: Isn't it...
Nicous: 就是
Nicous: Exactly.
Katrina: 我看过很多玩的很好的男生朋友
Katrina: I've seen a lot of guy friends who are close.
Katrina: 很好的男生朋友
Katrina: Very close guy friends.
我摇一个都会叫的
Katrina: If I shake one, he'll call.
Katrina: 我摇一个怎么讲
Katrina: If I shake one, how to say...
Katrina: 就是因为他在场内啊
Katrina: It's because he's in the field.
Shure: 因为他在北京
Shure: Because he's in Beijing.
Nicous: 不 在他就觉得
Nicous: No, he just thinks...
Nicous: 昂勒密
Nicous: Oh, come on.
Katrina: 为什么不能邀请好朋友
Katrina: Why can't we invite good friends?
刘婷:什么叫帮你吃一顿
Liu Ting: What do you mean, help you eat?
Nicous: 昂勒密
Nicous: Oh, come on.
刘婷:你不是自己想吃吗
Liu Ting: Don't you want to eat it yourself?
Shure: 不 我们我们先开
Shure: No, let's start first.
Shure: 开了他边喝边聊行不行
Shure: Start and he can chat while drinking, okay?
Jake:走走走边喝
Jake: Go, go, drink while chatting.
Jake:边喝边聊
Jake: Drink and chat.
Nicous: 听我说你
Nicous: Listen to me...
Nicous: 有人说是这样的
Nicous: Some people say it's like this.
Jake:边喝边聊边喝走走走
Jake: Drink, chat, drink, go, go.
Shure: 哎呀哎呀 边喝边
Shure: Oh, come on, drink and...
Shure: 他他这个他这个
Shure: He, he, this, this...
Shure: 葡萄倒了快他妈1,000下了已经
Shure: The grapes have spilled like a thousand times already.
Nicous: 哎听我说这样的
Nicous: Hey, listen, it's like this...